une
laurier sainte marie dans l'est du
centre ville de montréal a longtemps été
la circonscription de gilles duceppe
c'est grâce aux électeurs d'ici qu'il
est devenu le premier député du bloc
québécois battant un certain denis
coderre mais en 2011
la vague orange a déferlé et gilles
duceppe lui aussi a été emporté quatre
ans plus tard une lutte à deux s'annonce
la députée sortante hélène laverdière
qu'on voit ici il ya deux semaines dans
une manifestation pour radio canada
semble apprécié par bien les électeurs
est très présente et je crois que
monsieur duceppe leur présenterai très
bien aussi mais tellement je trouve que
on est bien représentée par hélène
laverdière au niveau fédéral qui
j'espère sera continu ce que monsieur
duceppe vous l'appréciez oui très bien
oui c'est un bon représentant des faits
ça pourrait faire un très bon représente
ce qui est important pour moi c'est
l'économie en premier lieu c'est ce bon
le niqab touch pro vraiment je trouve
étonnant
plusieurs pancartes électorales des
candidate du npd et des libéraux ont été
vandalisées dans la circonscription
rappelons quand même que le niqab reste
un enjeu dans cette campagne
gilles duceppe dont la position est plus
ferme sur la question combien en
profiter comme il espère profiter de la
baisse du npd dans les sondages tous les
dimanches depuis la muse des bénévoles
du bloc québécois se joint donc à leur
chef pour une opération porte-à-porte
dans laurier sainte marie
je pense aussi que c'est important de
garder le bloc en place pour démontrer
quand même que le québec est différent
c'est le seul parti au fédéral qui
représente une province à la politique
je crois plus ou moins mais en même
temps je vois que ça peut donner ce
résultat mais c'est pas encore assez
clair pour moi dans mon esprit
convaincre les électeurs 1 1 pour
remonter la pente abrupte
gilles duceppe avait perdu par 5300 voie
en 2000 ans ici jean-sébastien cloutier
radio canada montréal